[Music]
that's the thx sound I like the tension
resolution a little bit disconcerning
like a palate cleanser like wake up stop
talking to one another and then I'll
sudden we're resolved on this it's
really nice ending it's like a gentle
rub on the back everything's going to be
okay you'll be online soon
I think it's playing on middle C which
is kind of chord to everyone's most used
to hearing although I think it's been
pitched down over the years I believe it
was stereo and and they brought it into
mana its attention-grabbing
you've been downloading something if it
suddenly stops and it drops into your
download folder now this is telling me
that I've done something wrong the decay
is really really final it's in a lower
frequency it's very short it is
literally like a walls more of a general
notification sound very very similar
same applies it's quite a sudden decay
to kind of show you that you can't go
any further
skeuomorphism is when we take a design
function and use it to mimic something
in the real world so maybe a better way
of saying is this sound has been
designed to replicate the expression of
throwing trash
so that's the windows 95 startup sound
created by Brian Eno it's kind of a an
opening of a window you start looking
through something and I think if you
remember there was kind of lots of
windows that kind of faded out it's kind
of taken that visual cue and kind of
recreated this kind of reverberation of
that window continuing its triumph but
of mice work is over
[Music]
where did you get this one
this is the sound of two modems actually
having a conversation that sound is not
exactly the same every time I've
actually looked at a blueprint of how
the sound works and it genuinely is a
conversation that one will say one thing
and that will lead another to say
another thing is it's weirdly cute
it's the interval one five eight it was
never actually intended to be on the
iPhone it was developed for what was
going to be application called sound Jam
probably one of the most heard sounds
the last few years this one became the
default because in Bell Labs were doing
a bunch of research on what ringtones
would get people's attention and
distract them from what they were doing
and get them to pick up their telephone
the range of the human voice is the
range that you hear and they also found
that sounds that were the went from
called their quietest moment to the
loudest moment within three to five
seconds were easiest to grab a users
attention so in 2009 this was heard 1.8
billion times a day which is 20000 times
a second that melody comes from an old
Spanish composer Francisco tárrega who
only ever played in front of very small
groups of people and normally as friends
so ironically it's become one of the
most listened to pieces of music in
history the winner of a make our
ringtone competition if you look at the
logo a dart at E and then three dots if
you look at it backwards it actually
kind of you know sounds like what that
looks like
do-do-do-do-do yeah those sounds are
human sounds they're voices they're
blowing into ketchup bottles its speech
bubbles underwater obviously skypes of
our conversation is about getting in
touch one another and speaking and the
way they visualize that is through the
speech bubble obviously in the air and
you blow a bubble doesn't make any sound
but underwater bubbles have a very
distinct sound oh yeah this this sound
kind of descends it feels like it
was kind of popping and being sucked
down so what I really like about this is
the way they've tied it in as a duet the
sound going up for for sending and going
down for receive like semi optically
ties in with what's actually happening
kind of a playful back and forth it's
quite unobtrusive is quite you can come
back to me when you're ready
yeah Facebook just redid like a year or
so ago all of their sounds rumor has it
that the the old sound was actually a
major seven chord which when played on
the keyboard is FAC e it can cut through
if you're listening to music I think in
a way that's effective it feels like so
types and then that Papa ba is someone's
writing another example of skeuomorphism
those are very tactile sounds I think
originally those sounds were very
important for people to to get that
feedback and understand I think you know
less and less do we need those types of
sounds I think that made the decision to
go with a more old-school typewriter
because it helped users more it's just
so in-your-face I found it really funny
when I found out that apparently an
eighth of the space on Sonic the
Hedgehog went to making sure you heard
that which just shows how important
marketing is
[Music]
so this this is the PlayStation 1 sound
I think they're trying to take you into
another world it's calming in a space
vibe Conaway
so they moved to more of a orchestral
tuning instantly there's a center
community and I think that's not a
coincidence on PlayStation 3 we have a
lot of people connecting it was it was
no longer just me in my front room it
was me and whoever else was online and
you can you can hear that very much
tracking exactly what's going on just at
the end you just hear this kind of
breath and again I think they must have
been thinking the same thing as
Playstations that was a big leap forward
in connectivity you have to bring humans
into the equation because they're now
having conversations online viral by
Xbox II a sport it's in the game that
guy's pretty excited about EA Sports
[Music]
this is the Intel sound which is
obviously the most heard sonic logo in
the world ever I think something like
90% people recognize that sound as Intel
a lot of people think of it as four
notes but there's actually that first
note so it's five altogether there were
actually 20 sounds on the very first
note one of which is an anvil
more there have been seven MGM Lions and
I believe there was no sound originally
and then they rerecord it a lion roaring
that dates back way back to radio
they're still consistently using it
across television today I had this issue
where the announcers were rubbish you're
playing it or one play louder than the
other set actually into building
machines to play these three notes they
were actually became so important that
they will have backup machines in case
the main machine broke it sounds like
it's expressing a gavel to me right it's
actually the sound of a jail door
closing okay for many of the sounds that
you hear on your computers on your
phones there's a lot of time a lot of
energy a lot of love that goes into the
creation of those those sounds sometimes
we're looking at a few weeks but other
times we're looking at you know a few
months I think we're going to get into
that era where we no longer sentimental
about the original telephone ringing
will become sentimental about the
Facebook ring or the Skype ring and
they'll be past issues to that that was
a lot some light it's not